that very question to the former Foreign
Secretary David Miliband who's no
president and chief executive of the
International Rescue Committee I think
you're absolutely right to say that the
test of these summits is not the words
but the actions the UN summit happening
tomorrow monday is at the moment plagued
by political division between different
countries and that's put the onus on a
second summit on Tuesday that President
Obama has called we're practical
concrete steps need to be taken first of
all to increase the amount and
effectiveness of international
humanitarian aid secondly to raise the
number of refugees the most vulnerable
widows and orphans who are resettled
into richer countries and thirdly to
take on the people smugglers who have
made such profit out of human misery
over the last year or two well the
European Union talk of and we we know
that the pressures that have been put on
so many members of that union by
refugees talk of a global shared
responsibility do you see then coming
out of this global quotas I think that
it's premature to talk about that
because eighty-five percent of the
world's refugees are in poor countries
not in rich countries it's countries
like Kenya Pakistan middle-income
country like Turkey has over two million
refugees a country like Lebanon has over
one and a half million refugees what I
think we do need is a clear commitment
from the richer countries that the
smaller number of vulnerable less than
ten percent probably round five percent
of the most vulnerable victims of war
need to be resettled in countries like
the US the UK across europe etc we
actually need the gulf and other
countries to participate as well but
there is an obvious need not just to
deal with the symptoms of the problem
that's the fleeing refugees but also to
deal with the humanitarian conditions in
countries like Lebanon Jordan Pakistan
that are driving people to seek a refuge
in Europe in the first place so what
does that mean for the United Kingdom at
the moment twenty thousand or so
refugees over five years that doesn't
sound like a lot you're right to say
that the UK commitment is very small
what I always explain to people is that
the current government's commitment to
Syrian refugees the 20,000 over five
years that you referred to is the
equivalent of six refugees /
parliamentary constituency you know that
I used to represent south shields in
Parliament there's no way anyone can
persuade me that six refugees is going
to overwhelm the 65,000 people who are
residents of South Shields and I think
there's quite a lot of scope for Theresa
May to come to the UN and to the Obama
summit on Tuesday and say look the UK
has a really good record on
international overseas aid we're a
leader the UK is a leader through the
department for international development
on global humanitarian help but we can
also make a greater contribution beyond
the six refugees / parliamentary
constituency frankly the UK should be
saying will will take 20 or 25,000 a
year so four times the current level 25
refugees / parliamentary constituency
rather than just six because countries
like Canada are already doing that the
Canadian government came in last year I
was meeting them just this week they
committed to take 25,000 people it's a
country of half the population of the UK
so I think the UK could do more on the
refugee resettlement side to match the
frankly exemplary performance that the
UK has on international humanitarian aid
and let's focus on Syria now and first
of all in relation to I suppose the
first question I asked you about the
United Nations and how effective it can
be or has been in trying to sort it out
there doesn't it tell us everything
about the UN that it's the United States
and Russia who by and large have
brokered this ceasefire well my
organization has 2,000 staff inside
Syria we had five people killed in an
acid or russian bombing raid about a
month ago who are running a hospital in
der I in the southwest of the country
the reports I'm getting from the ground
are that the ceasefire is more or less
holding there's localized outbreaks of
violence but the truth about the UN
which speaks to the broader question
you're asking is that it's only as
strong as the strong member states
within it and how they work together so
when Russia and America are divided as
they have been on the Syria issue over
the last five years the UN becomes
paralyzed
and we've seen the effects of that with
the 500,000 killed the 5 million
refugees the 7 million internally
displaced and Syria is a poster child
for what happens when the great powers
are divided on the big issues of the day
and the fact that the US and Russia are
finally working together is only the
beginning because the truth is that all
of us know that a short term ceasefire
needs to be complemented by a serious
political process that addresses the
fundamental problem of Syria which is
that the Assad government is
illegitimate in the eyes of the majority
of the people and that's something that
needs to be addressed so well you know
the next question then where might it
lead it's a big if of course in the
early days of this ceasefire but in
terms of a more lasting settlement the
calms things down in which people can
hopefully return to the country does it
require the removal of President Assad I
think that the critical issue is that
while the current government which has
been responsible for the majority of the
deaths has ultimate power then there is
going to be an ongoing civil conflict of
an absolutely fundamental kind and the
issue that needs to be addressed is what
the so-called transition the the
original agreement in 2012 in Geneva
talked about a transition from the
current government and the big question
is what's it a transition to the
Russians have always argued it's going
to be a transition to chaos and there
hasn't been a proper denunciation of
what the new power structure will be
various proposals have been made by
civil society groups but from our
position as a humanitarian organization
it's not our job to choose the
government is our job to say that the
civilians deserve a government that will
respect their rights and one which both
the great powers and the regional powers
are willing to expect respect let me ask
you for your political analysis of the
effects of the refugee crisis do you see
it as being linked to the rise of
nationalist anti-immigration parties I
think there's no question that the fear
among many voters that borders are not
controlled has contributed to a rise of
what I would call the polarization
around the politics of refugees and
immigration secondly I think it's also
the case that the confusion between a
refugee who is fleeing for his or her
life and an immigrant who is fleeing for
a better life it's not the one is good
and the other is bad it's just that
different the confusion of those two
categories has also made the politics
very difficult and thirdly I think it's
reasonable to point out that in the wake
of the financial crisis the straightened
economic circumstances of Western
countries has contributed to a sense of
disenfranchisement and disenchantment
from my point of view the absolutely
essential thing is that we preserve the
fundamental fact that riff refugees are
fleeing for their lives you only take to
the boats of the Mediterranean in
absolute desperation and do you see then
you see a dollop of those sentiments of
alienation presumably in the brexit vote
in the UK do you think that that
ultimately will have to come to a a
second vote even if it's just about the
shape and form of the brexit settlement
I think the truth is that not only does
the government of the UK not know how
the brig zyk negotiation is going to be
conducted or even what they're
negotiating platform is going to be but
none of us know how long this is going
to take or what the eventual outcome is
going to be people have clearly voted by
four percent to leave the European Union
that has to be respected the government
has to take forward its commitments in
that regard and I think for people like
me who argued very strongly including on
your program for Britain to remain a
member of the European Union we've got
to respect the result it would be a dead
end to start for me to start saying how
this is ultimately going to end up what
I do think i should say is that there
need to be some very clear negotiating
tests for the government the government
had a responsibility to have a
negotiation that does maximize the
economic opportunity for britain both in
terms of the market for goods and
services but also in terms of inward
investment it does have to address the
immigration issues that have been raised
in the course of the campaign which were
clearly part of the result and Mr
Miliband let's ask you about the
American political scene we know how
closely you and Hillary Clinton worked
together while she was Secretary of
State newer Foreign Secretary are you
offering her any advice on her current
campaign that's charming of you to
suggest that I should do so but she's
got plenty of advisors and most
important she's got a very clear idea of
her own about the campaign that she
wants to run and about the way in which
she wants to lead at the country I mean
I can tell you what I'm sure you've
covered which is that this is a
tumultuous campaign the only rule is
that there are no rules at all and i
think that the election is going to come
into focus over the next three or four
weeks one thing that I tell people here
that is different from the brexit
referendum is that in the brig zyk case
the status quo was quite well known and
in many ways not liked but the
alternative Briggs it was completely
unknown that was the referendum in an
election campaign especially one like
the one in the US at the moment both
sides are very well known both mrs.
Clinton and Donald Trump have been
fixtures of the national scene for 25
years and so this is very different from
a brexit situation it's a competition
between two very well known quantities
and I think that will in the end be
important in the final decision that
people make speculation about jobs
concern you Mr Miliband if you are
retaining your British citizenship is a
return to the Labour Party is that off
the agenda as well yeah I'm focused on
my job here in the US I've just just
finished my foot my three years here
obviously it grieves people like me that
the Labour Party should be so far from
power a country like the UK desperately
needs I mean any advanced industrialized
democracy frankly desperately needs a
credible committed alternative
government and that's not just good for
democracy it's actually essential for
the functioning of the political system
and at the moment the UK voter doesn't
have that kind
option we'll see what happens in the
labor election that's coming up but
there is a fundamental argument that
needs to be had in center left parties
and it's not just about the tactics to
win it's about the values that we stand
for and the way in which we take forward
those values and radically change
circumstances and the argument with
jeremy corbyn is not just about his
electoral tactics it's about the fact
that many of us think he's wrong on on
key issues whether it be opening coal
mines reopening coal mines or Britain's
role in NATO mr miliband great talking
to you thank you so much David Miliband
thank you very much indeed